OP NATESWHO THREATENEDTU
SAN LUCAS STARTED AIR DROPPING
ERNTINUES WHILE WE'RE ON
THE GROUND, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
K TO TE, EVERYBODY
IS GOING TO HAVE TT OFF, WE
HAVEGE
D  IS GOING TO B
RUINED.
THINGNG NAKED PICTURES,T'CABO.
I
H ME NOW.    TEASING THIS STORY
MORNING.
THEY WERE AIR DROPPING NAKED D ?
'TWHY
Y WOULD DO TANA GOOD IA ORNYHEM.
FLIGH WEEK,  CLUCAS, T AIRLINE,
PASSR OTVIAN HER GIRLFRIEN ASOMI
DEPI
ACCEPTED IT, OUT IWAS DE P
I WONDER WT
SO ANOTHER PASSENG TALERTS
ON IS AING PTUND IT  US, FT ATTP
NOUND, I  PE HE'S LIKE EVER T
PHONES, SO THEY ENDEDRIGHT, EVD
TOEH SENDINGAVAROUNDK OFF,
T APPARENTLY THIS IS, YO
KNOW, KE YET NI
DON'T KNOW, TECH
CAUTIONY , THAT IF
YOU HAVE A MESSAGE  ON YOU
PHONYINGOMO
AIR DROP YOUU SA
>>
SECURITY ANDL- HOULD SOUTHWESTA,
CUSTOMERS AND HEHIGHEST PRIOL MA
AL PROBLEM, OU
EMPLOYEES ADDRES TORT THE COMFO.
>>